[APPLAUSE]
JI: It's really--
I'm very happy to be here today.
Thanks for having me.
I don't know what
you guys envision
today's going to be like.
I was looking
around and it said I
will talk about the behind
the scenes of being a pianist.
It's too complex to just call it
behind the scenes of a pianist.
So I'll talk about
the complexity of it,
I guess, and how each
pianist or musician has,
obviously, like you and I have
different experiences in life.
So today, what I'm
here to talk about is--
I want to sort of
reassure, or just
tell everybody flat out
that times may be tough.
The world may be not
so great right now.
We have amazing things that
have happened technologically,
but then as a result
of that, there
may be some things
that may lack--
humanity and
compassion and empathy.
And I wanted to talk about these
subjects from my vantage point
and from my experiences of
being in the classical music
industry, being a
musician and a performing
artist since the age of 10.
And so just a
little background--
I was signed to a very
commercial artist management
company called IMG Artists.
You guys know IMG
Models, IMG Sports.
I was the youngest
one to ever be signed.
And when I was 10, I started
traveling three to four times
a month playing
concerts, making money,
and dealing with grown-ups.
But it all kind of started
because I was very talented.
I was, quote unquote, "a
prodigy," as they say.
And I just had an innate
joy and passion to perform.
And through navigating my
career when I was little,
I got to come in contact with so
many different types of people,
people from all over
the states of America--
the South, the Midwest,
Northeast, you name it--
and then Europe, and then Asia.
And so from a very
young age, I got
to experience firsthand
different types
of personalities, different
types of cultures,
different types of perception of
life and perception of society.
And when you're 10 or 11,
you can't really distinguish,
oh, this person is this or
this person is that, right?
You kind of take it
all in from the basis
of how they interact with you.
And I'm pretty sure no
matter where you go,
people are going to be nice
to a 10-year-old, right?
They're not going to put
the same sort of pressure
or the same sort
of-- even if I was,
quote unquote, "a
professional," everybody
was really kind towards me.
And now in my late 20s, I think
about all the little things
that we are concerned about
when it comes to social conduct
and stuff like that.
I never really experienced
that when I was little.
And so I say that's sort of
like a double-edged sword,
because maybe I am a little
bit out of touch with reality
in terms of how you grew up--
going through the
regular schools,
and then going into the
job force at a certain age,
and growing up with
your peers that
are the same age as you
that receive information
at the same rate as you.
I might not have
received information
at the same rate
as you, but I've
experienced things a little
bit different than you.
So I think I can be here today
to talk about my experiences
and tell you that, or remind you
that we can do things every day
in our day-to-day things to make
this world a little bit more
filled with
understanding people.
ALEX HK CHUNG: So Ji, please
tell us a little bit more
to better orient the audience.
How has the piano
playing inspired you,
and what kept you
going in that regard?
JI: So I want to
start off by saying
when I was about 18 years
old, I had to leave the stage.
I had to sort of quit playing
music for a little while.
And at that moment, I quit with
no intention of coming back.
But I did that because I
realized at a very young age
that I love music, but I
also love having a purpose
and I also love people.
And as you probably know,
classical music is not
the most mainstream, you know?
The first thing that
doesn't comes to your mind
when you think of
classical music
is, oh, I want to go
and have an experience.
It'll be a life-changing
experience for me.
That's not the first
thing you think of, right?
Like, if I were to go to,
say, a Beyonce concert,
I know I'm in for a treat.
I know I'm going to walk
out of that stadium feeling
like my brain has just been
like [EXPLOSION SOUND EFFECT]..
But you don't have
that same anticipation
with classical music.
You go because probably, A,
if you like classical music,
you go because you
like the performer.
B, you go maybe because it's
sort of the high-society
cultural thing.
And we're all guilty of this.
We like those things.
Those are the social constructs
that we have set for ourselves,
so of course we're going to
do things that follow that.
And so that's one of them.
And that probably gives way
to the sort of dwindling
of the industry, per se.
But going back to my point,
I just lost the reason--
if I was going to do this--
I was 18 years old.
And normal kids when
they're 18, they're
like, oh, what college
am I going to go to?
Do I even have a major
that I want to study?
But for me-- in hindsight
it was not such a big deal.
But when I was 18 I
felt like, oh my god,
this is what I have to do
for the rest of my life.
I'm not enjoying this.
I'm not having any fun.
I feel like I'm going on stage
and being like a circus act,
because all these
people come and watch
me play because I'm, quote
unquote, "a prodigy,"
and they just want
to be impressed.
But I thought to myself,
this is not why I love music.
I love performing,
but I didn't do it
so that I could fit
some sort of format
that we have already
created in the industry.
I felt that as I got
older, I had something more
to say with the music.
And because of the things
that were happening
around me socially,
it obviously inspires
and feeds into the way
I listen and perceive
and translate music.
But as with most industries,
we scream for change
but we're very reluctant
for change, right?
And so that was
exactly the case.
And so that's why I left.
But when I left, I left with
a sort of disdain and disgust
for it, because I didn't
feel that sort of passion
in what music did to me
when I was younger anymore.
But I quit for two years.
I did a lot of different things.
One of the things I
made sure that I did
was to collaborate with
other genres of art--
visual art, more what we are--
as modern-day teenagers--
are all in tune with.
And I was just
trying to figure out
a way to tell beautiful
stories in more ways
than one, because
I believed and I
was hopeful in the
power of numbers.
And so eventually, everything
kind of led me back to music.
And it gave me a
whole new perception
on how I understand this
music and how I want
to convey it to the people.
And for so long, I had been
beaten over the head with,
this is how you're
supposed to do it.
This is the format-- like, blah,
blah, blah, whatever it is.
But I think-- for so long,
I didn't pay attention
to my own voice.
You know?
And when I was like
23, 24, I started
searching for that voice again.
I started searching for
how I felt when I listened
to music when I was seven.
I started searching
for, there must be--
I came back to this
because I realized
classical music has
so much emotions
in one sitting, so many
emotions that we can cover.
And it was so shocking
to me that I could so
easily understand and
relate to a piece of music
that was written by
Bach 300 years ago,
and that I could play that
piece of music on stage
and you will feel what I felt.
To me, that's really cool.
I mean, I don't think
any science can really
explain that sort of lineage
or that sort of streamline
of human emotions that get
carried through and passed on
over hundreds of years.
So that was really
fascinating to me.
And then I dug a
little deeper and then
I asked myself, if
I can sit you down
and you could feel
all these things
and it could be like
a therapy session
almost, if you will,
because you feel everything
and it kind of lets
everything out,
why don't people want
to listen to this more?
And so that began
my sort of research
on, why do we have this sort
of compartmentalized notion
of what classical music is?
And a lot of people say,
oh, that's what we like.
I mean, some people just
don't like classical music.
Some people just
don't like pop music.
I understand that
and I respect that.
But perhaps you haven't been
looking for the right thing.
You haven't been privy
to the right things
to understand why I
make you feel that way.
And maybe if you were a little
bit more curious about why
you felt the way you felt when
I played the piece that way,
then maybe it could
lead into trying
to understand from a very
different lens, right?
And so the next point
I want to make--
and I want to show a couple
of different examples--
is I want to kind of
stay away from the music
for a little while and
talk about everyday things.
And so I have a story--
I was here in February
for about a month,
and then I went
back to the States.
And I was in an elevator
and I was mid-phone call.
But I got into the elevator.
And most elevators in New York
City are complete dead zones,
and so you lose
service completely.
But here, everything works.
Cellphones work
everywhere, right?
And so I had just
gotten so accustomed
to just being on
the phone, and so I
didn't think twice about it.
And when I was in the
elevator-- and it was
like a corporate building, too.
And New York is pretty densely
populated with liberal people--
people that want
equality, people
that think those are good
things to society, right?
But I was in the elevator and I
was like, hello, hello, hello?
And then these three people were
like, you're in an elevator.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was like, oh, OK.
And I got really flushed.
And then I went home
and I thought about it,
and it bothered me a little bit.
Because I wasn't trying to be
a douchebag in the elevator
and say, oh, I can't--
there are people
like that, of course.
But that was not what
I was trying to do.
And then I was like, maybe
it's because I had just
been so accustomed to just
being on the phone all the time,
and had I been in New York
this whole entire time maybe
I'd have been more aware of
that and I would have shut
my phone off or something or
told the other person that I
was going into the elevator.
But for people who say that they
want equality and are liberal
and support all these
things, and then
on a very plain,
simple, everyday thing
like talking on the
phone in the elevator,
they give you a dirty look
and they make a comment.
If they had just thought,
oh, why is he doing that?
It could be a number
of different things.
I could have been the douchebag.
I could have been
somebody who had
some sort of mental
disability and didn't
know social etiquette.
Or I could have just been me.
But instead of throwing
that dirty look,
they could have thought twice,
or maybe a second longer--
or even the fact that like,
oh, maybe he's not white.
He's Asian.
Maybe phones work in elevators
in Asia, which they do.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think we as human race
now in modern-day society,
we kind of fall short at
the length at which we will
go to understand other people.
And you could blame
that on social media.
ALEX HK CHUNG: How
has that experience
transformed into your
expressiveness, into piano?
Or was that concert
music that you wanted--
JI: Of course.
Like, I get bottled up and
I get really frustrated,
and then it just
kind of pours out.
And I want to figure out--
everybody wants to tie in what
they do, and to mean something,
right?
I mean, I'm sure
you all do what you
do because you wanted to be
a part of a greater meaning
and purpose in life.
And that's exactly what I do.
And I want to encourage
and urge everybody
to just go that extra step
to maybe think about why,
and give everybody the
benefit of the doubt
and see that there is a
reason for everything.
If a douchebag was on the
phone, then you don't say that.
You say, oh, well,
maybe he needs
to be led a different way.
He needs to be shown
a different path.
There's ways you could do this.
I mean, we do this with puppies.
If you get a new puppy
and they do an accident,
we don't scold them.
We don't yell at them.
We don't hit them.
We put them where
they need to go.
No matter how many times it
takes them to get it right,
we do it.
Right?
I think the amount
of responsibilities
that we take on ourselves
for our pets should
be the same for humans--
and not just your immediate
relatives and your friends,
but everybody.
We are all responsible
for one another.
And I'm sure everybody in this
room want this kind of life
where we all understand, right?
But I'm very guilty of this.
I'm talking right
now because I want
to remind myself to be a better
person, because I did something
today earlier on that
counteracts exactly what I'm
saying right now.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX HK CHUNG: So how has
your experience like these
transferred to your, I
guess, concert pianist?
As a performer, as a musician,
how has the experience
changed or inspired you
to connect the dots,
to think a little bit more
about different people
or to understand
a little bit more?
How has this quest led to
where you are right now?
JI: So being a
classical musician
means being a sort of messenger,
messenger of music that has
been written a long time ago.
It all depends on
the interpretation.
But at the core of it is a human
being that wrote this music.
And this human being was
probably writing this music
because he was inspired by his
surroundings, his emotions,
and all these things.
So it's not just
a piece of music.
It's someone's soul, right?
And I'm going to give you an
example of this one piece.
So this is a piece, a song
written by Robert Schumann.
He was a composer
in the 19th century.
So he wrote this song,
and it's called Widmung.
And it translates to Dedication.
And he wrote this
song to his wife.
And that's the
gist of the story.
It's a love, romantic story.
And so I am living in 2018.
I look at this piece of
music for the first time
and I see a couple
of things, right?
I see some German on top.
What does that mean?
Sincere and lively, right?
What do I take from that?
I don't know.
Let's leave it.
Sincere but lively,
like happily sincere?
I'm confused.
Can you press it again?
Thank you.
I have the time, the
meter, which is 3:2.
And some of you know
music, some of you may not.
But that basically means--
can you press?
That there are three--
one more time.
Three beats in one
measure, and a measure
is what those lines
are, the black lines.
Can you press one more time?
And then we have in this
case-- and not in every case,
but because this is
a song transcription,
we have the lyric on top.
And that's the
English translation.
And just one more time.
But I want to pay
attention to this.
So this is in the
very opening bar.
And it goes--
[PLAYING NOTES]
And it's throughout
the whole entire piece.
Robert Schumann was-- and
correct me if I'm wrong,
but most musicians I know
are not very extroverted.
They're not very confident
people socially, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
Disclaimer.
They're not.
And so if it was
a confident person
and he was super
leisurely and they
wanted to express their love,
maybe it would have been like--
[PLAYING CONFIDENTLY]
But since he is--
he's nervous.
He doesn't know what
she is going to say.
So he's like
second-guessing himself.
[PLAYING TIMIDLY]
And all throughout.
It just-- he keeps
going and pulling back,
keeps going and pulling back.
But that's love, right?
That's a relationship
to this day, right?
You're not always
so comfortable.
You always need to
be on your toes.
This song was written
more than 200 years ago.
Still, the same
shit happens today.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so.
I'm going to play this later
so you hear the whole thing.
But can you press another one?
OK, so another point that I want
to make that I learned through
my daily self-deprecating
routines of practicing--
and I practice about, on a good
day, six to seven hours a day.
And it's just-- it's not pretty.
It's loud and it's annoying,
and you don't want to sit there.
It's not, oh, you're
going to practice.
I'm going to listen to
some beautiful music.
Never.
And I'll show you why.
But this is a passage from
Beethoven's Piano Sonata Number
23.
It's in the third movement.
And this particular passage
is technically challenging.
And so we as musicians,
or instrumentalists,
spend hours and hours to
perfect the technique.
So the technique and
musicality and emotion
are not two separate things.
You need the technique in
order to convey the emotions.
If you don't have
the technique--
and we live in a society where
the standard is so high--
then the emotions which
are even there won't even
get across poignantly or at
all, because to some ear,
if they can't play
it right then they
just completely
negate any sort of--
so our job is to make sure
that everything is solid
and there so that we
can highlight or put
a spotlight on what
needs to be expressed.
So we do these
ridiculous exercises.
Can you press one?
Thank you.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to put emphasis on
the first beat, the first note
of every beat.
So I'm going to
just do two bars.
And so it sounds
something like this.
[PLAYING DRAMATICALLY]
And can you hit it again?
Now I'm going to do--
[PLAYING IN ANOTHER STYLE]
Can you hit it again?
That's on the third beat.
[PLAYING IN ANOTHER STYLE]
And so on and so forth.
In doing this--
I mean, so many
musicians do this kind
of regimented practicing,
and this exact type
of practicing in
order to get a passage
like this solid and steady.
And I was thinking about this.
Why do we do this?
And I was thinking
about my fingers.
If you look at your
fingers, try doing this.
Try holding this
and trying to play
your fourth finger,
your ring finger
without lifting
any other finger.
That's weird, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Your fourth finger is so weak.
But each finger has
its own characteristic.
Each finger has its own
strengths and weaknesses.
I thought about this in
a societal point of view.
What if these five fingers
were different people?
In order to have complete
harmony and unison
and rhythm in time--
the whole thing about
music is the expression
within a given time, right?
And history and
society and people
are constantly moving together
in the never-stopping time.
You can't stop time.
You always have to go with time.
And so the reason why I
isolate these certain notes is
so that I put emphasis
or I strengthen
that one note at one point,
and then another finger
with another, different
way of practicing,
if that makes any sense.
I'm like rambling on right now.
But anyways, I thought why
don't we literally just force
ourselves to put
ourselves in a situation
where we may be next to
this one person at one time,
and then another day we may
be next to another person--
someone that's completely
different from us,
someone that doesn't
understand us,
or we don't understand them?
But perhaps if we
practiced this more often,
like I practice this
every day, then we
will have perfect
steady harmony in time.
So if I keep doing
that, you'll hear it.
Because I'll play it.
And hopefully it's good.
But here's another point--
and I'm just doing this to save
my own ass-- if it's not good,
it's because we have
to keep doing it.
So yeah, so that's it.
ALEX HK CHUNG: Thanks, Ji,
to sharing your experience
and connecting that
with how you practice
and how you think about
practicing that difficult note.
JI: Oh, I do have one
more thing that I want
to say before I play, though.
And so right now
I'm at this point
where I want to present
classical music in a way
that as a whole, when I play
a number of pieces together,
has a narrative and a story
that we all can relate to.
So some of the things that I
do may not be so conventional,
because say for instance--
like, this is the third movement
of the sonata.
I'm making a program
where I begin
the program with the third
movement of the sonata.
Usually if you're
playing a sonata,
you play the whole
damn sonata first
and you play with the
first movement beginning.
But I don't want to
play the whole sonata.
I just want to play
the third movement
and go on to the next piece.
This is very unorthodox.
But the music has its
components in which I
can deliver the message to you.
And so maybe this can
help you better understand
the music in general.
And this is just
one little fragment
of a pianist in the
world doing his part
to make you feel something,
because that's what
music is at the end of the day.
ALEX HK CHUNG: Thank you, Ji.
So without further ado, let's
hear how you want to express
and what you want
to express to us.
[MUSIC - BEETHOVEN,
"PIANO SONATA NO.
23"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]